today is not a win for any individual or
cause it's a win for parliamentary
sovereignty the separation of powers and
the independence of our British courts
crucially today's ruling confirms that
we are a nation governed by the rule of
law laws that everyone even the prime
minister is not above do not let the
government play down the seriousness of
the judgment today a unanimous judgment
they have spoken unequivocally and what
I say to the Prime Minister is to repeat
lady Hales words the order was a blank
piece of paper Parliament was not for
wrote MPs should turn up for work
tomorrow and get on with scrutinizing
this government I would like to express
my sincere thanks to my legal team Lord
Panik
Tom Hickman Myshkin Daria we have had
twice in three years to come to the
Supreme Court to ensure that the
government does not put itself above the
law
the ruling today speaks volumes
this Prime Minister must open the doors
of Parliament tomorrow
MPs must get back and be brave and bold
in holding this unscrupulous government
to account thank you